so I am Agassi towers and my talk is the
dangers of mindless forecasting and my
talk can be summarized in a joke so back
in the day when I was starting to do uh
data science I thought that Aya was
scary that the science of the surgery
and it requires the PHD and computer
region was magic now it's all boiled
times just in five lines of code in
Python and this is a problem
because uh AI is now a buzzword and AI
is being commercialized and big
companies say you need bigger better
models that took a lot of time to
compute to be to calculate the highest
metrics and use our path platform and
not do it in two or three seconds and
give us the earn the money so uh this is
the problem we face because uh I want to
uh I want you to understand that there
should be a paradox shift because uh you
don't always need the models that have
the biggest highest the best metrics
because those models don't apply to the
real world so uh let's uh have a quiz
find the connection between those
pictures first of all uh points to those
extra points to those who can say tell
me what the first picture is
this is the density function for normal
distribution the first picture the
second I hope you know Kim Kardashian
Okay the third picture is a mock-up of
some buildings
and the fourth picture is a neural net
so are there some ideas all right
all right yes there are the connection
between those pictures that those are
all models uh we besides the second one
because strictly speaking uh the second
one isn't the scientific model
a person just an Instagram model okay
but everything we do everything we try
to understand everything is a model even
ER understanding of a word is in
complete model of the world and each has
its he or his own incomplete
understanding of the world
so ah
and Mathematics has a beauty and
Mathematics is the nearest thing that
can describe the world okay and further
from the mathematics the uh uh more
noisier are the models so mathematics
rightly viewed possess not only truth
but Supreme Beauty as quoted by Bernard
Russell and I wanted to show you a video
clip here because we have the reality
some probability and models those things
are model this is how the reality one we
want to understand we want to uh
predict everything is a model even we
can go and when modeling we can go from
simple to most complex for example if we
want to model us an airplane let's say
we have a million dollar on our plane we
don't we want to understand to model we
can do it in quite a few different ways
for example I can take a piece of paper
this is the thing I want to model this
is my basis
unfold it in couple of ways
Let's Fold it in okay
fold it in all right couple of Folds
and we have a paper airplane and we can
launch it
and
do some calculations and based on these
models find
some truth but this is a simple model
because you see you saw how quickly I
made that model how easy it is to
analyze it and when we are in that
extreme
it will give us a lot of Errors because
it doesn't represent the world truly
fully and on the other end we can have
extremely hard models that
try to include and describe everything
imaginable
but those models
are problematic as well and they can
give
uh
result that are harder to explain harder
to understand
and uh results that can be very uh very
uh far from truth so we have two
extremes
all right let's go so there are some
Cycles you have seen the modeling Cycles
it doesn't mean it doesn't matter what
kind of cycle we use
what means is that it is a cycle because
modeling is not a linear thing you come
from one point uh analyze the data and
have the model it doesn't end there it's
a cycle and there is a question why is
it a cycle why the representation of
modeling always follows a cycle
that's the question and there are some
answers I want to think about usually I
uh let the Audi auditory to answer this
question but this is not that format so
firstly firstly
our the thing we want to models
constantly may change
even when modeling and having answer our
answers to the model may change the
systems for example we are predicting
the stock market and our predictions in
the future will affect the stock market
so does we must start the predictions
anew
because the system have changed secondly
secondly they may start with simpler
models to understand how the things work
and at the end of the first iteration
when we understood the simpler model the
F paper error plane we uh can't start
modeling with wood and so on before we
are an expert and can't do harder models
and thirdly thirdly
ah like uh those two things and
all right let's uh okay
uh and we'll go for this uh live note is
not a Kegel Championship like uh this is
our old flame to make pipe who uh
Chatters the truth so life is not a
Kegel Championship
most often models with inferior metrics
are better in the real world
so yeah I hope you know the story that
uh there was a champion there was a
uh a championship on Amazon to quote the
best model that can describe everything
so the the most complex model we use
with 30 different models uh that were
combined into each other and it gave a
lot of good results so it surpassed all
the expectation but this model was so
hard to implement so hard to quote and
so expensive that Amazon refused to use
it
because uh and right now there is uh
commercialization commercialization of
models and everybody says use our like
uh well I'll give an analogy to the
kitchen like you can cook a breakfast
with simple tan
but everybody says use our new uh like
uh commercial oven five thousand the
least it has the latest gpus that costs
a lot to prepare any meal but that's
like throwing a big huge expensive
solutions to a problem that can be done
in less expenses
so that's why I want to shift your
Paradigm because models that have the
highest metrics or
don't always aren't always the best in
the real world
sometimes models that are more
explainable
uh have
uh more explainable are easier to
understand at better
to illustrate this let's follow
a Kegel championship and that is famous
predicting Titanic survivors okay
Titanic surveillance so we have a simple
classification 3 for the tank okay that
has uh two branches we some may call it
this A faster Frugal tree because you
can't do this without using a computer
just following some lines and coming to
conclusion
okay so uh first it asks is the title Mr
or Mrs yes then there is a 16
survival chance no the third second
question third class then yes okay then
60 of survival everybody can understand
this model okay this is a simple model
okay and uh when viewed from metrics
okay a lot of people were doing
classification
you only use
errors
aeroc curse uh where May uh were
developed in the second world war and
I'll have an archaic name which I don't
like like so receiver operator something
it's just we care about the area under
the curve which went higher
then the model is better lower model
resource everybody speaking about that
no but like a few people only a few
people speak about accuracy sensitivity
specificity when doing models because
when modeling when doing classification
sometimes maybe sensitivity
is a better metric maybe specificity is
a better metric to use to understand
which model is better
Okay so
and uh I hope you do know that we must
uh divide our data into testing and
training sets I won't go into why it is
it should do but uh strictly speaking
when uh we are learning for the exam
we don't want the same questions we
learned on to be on the exam we want the
exam have the different questions so we
are dividing into training and testing
sets so to train and to test our model
so to test on the data that the training
the model hasn't seen yet okay so uh on
the spot cases we have the accuracy so
the right predictions divided to the
whole is 80 to 81 around there are no
strict numbers okay
sensitivity is around
75 78 and specific sensitivity is uh
it's just right uh right case is divided
to prediction and specific wrong cases
divided to the prediction okay
those are we should know this is our
model it does good it is good
and uh this is the ROC curve of the
model uh with different thresholds we
can change the direction to have
different sensitivities
sensitivity and specific threshold those
are two combined we can't hide High
sensitivity but close and specificity
and vice versa so imagine you want to do
track texting or in koi texting you want
to understand how much you want to have
false positives and how much you should
have false negatives the lower the false
negative the higher the false positive
and vice versa so this is uh the
threshold we are care about
so uh and we can do an overfeated
classification tree like overfeeded
models uh learn from uh can uh like we
can overfeed a model on testing
uh on training that here and it would
answer like we can can answer 100 of
cases of the training set but it'll fail
on new data this is a problem
okay this is an over 30 classification
three but as I told simpler models
sometimes are better
and let's see how this simple model what
the calcificationary which you can't
understand you can do by hand not using
a computer Compares two more
uh uh expensive and more uh harder
models so
this is an average so average estimation
so everybody has 39 of chance of
surviving so this is our Benchmark in
this case Aria under the curve is 50
accuracy is uh
63 64 so it's fine and uh barrier score
which I will not go into which is uh the
lower it's the sum of the errors okay
squared Earth uh the lower the better
okay uh is fine
this is a bit uh uh like a harder model
so all uh this is a simpler model of
human silver or maze do not so it has
higher
higher accuracy but we care about simple
classification three so from all the
models we have so we have uh over 50
classification to logistic regression
random Forest support Vector machine
natural natural networks average neutral
layers nearest neighbor so a lot of
different models and random Forest
neutral members are harder to compute
are harder to explain in all of these
questions the accuracy is higher
on simple classification tree
so using just classification three we
can
derive the same answer
and what about the Aria and the curve so
when using this Matrix random forest
does better and
uh like this kind of the forest models
exubus from the fourth have that problem
they maximize the metrics they have
higher metrics but is this good in the
real world you must ask
does uh will this uh there are some
problems I'll I'll talk about those
problems as well and buyer scores has
the best uh simple classification tree
besides besides those metrics aren't
strict they have a probability field
they have an error and within ah waiting
the error of the best
metric let's see Roc curve May lie the
simple classification model
so there must you should ask why should
I use a harder compute
model when
this number May lie inside
this value okay the error of this value
so
the modeling is a balance
okay is it is an art not only the
ready-made oven put your ingredients
here and you'll give the results its
preparation it's cooking it's art and
from one side you must understand that
your model must be as easy to understand
Implement as possible
from the other side are as hard to use
the most uh
uh the most fresh ingredients that
describe the whole system that you need
so it's a balancing act
because uh like there are some systems
that have a lot of variables should use
all of those variables no
you must understand which variables are
more important to use
okay so uh extra point to those who
knows who know
what this dinosaur represents uh like
show hands who know who should have seen
this dinosaur
only only one
all right couple of guys but uh let's
speak about the pitfalls of forecastings
first of all the games rules are
constantly changing so lack of
robustness so in real life the gay rules
always change so the data represented
one year ago six months ago the uh the
Casual links aren't the same that are
now
for example uh if you are trying to
model
uh to forecast a March a football match
so everything is constantly changing the
trainers are changing the players are
changing uh like some player may have an
injury so a lot of things are constantly
changing so the Casual links that apply
two or three months ago are the same
that apply now and you must understand
this I speak spoke about this when we
are sweating talking about the cycle and
constantly adjust your model or to uh
understand this and to build a model
that uh like uh plays into this for
example you not you are not analyzing
the whole teams but uh separate players
and they have their different curves of
performance separate uh trainers and
they have their
cursor performance and combining them
into one model for example Amanda
understand this
second small samples this is a problem
because uh any sample may be expensive
for example you are doing
bioengineering
and each sample takes time takes energy
takes resources and it is expensive
but uh like The World Is Random if you
throw dice a dice 10 times in a row and
repeat that experiment let's say a
million times there is a high
possibility that two uh two consecutive
like two causations of throat we'll
leave this is the same so they will be
color correlated but is there any
causality no
just randomly they are correlated okay
so uh like these expensive models random
Forest uh neutral Network when there are
a lot of data points
when you are doing uh there you have
um a small sample of data you must
understand that uh ital you may predict
on Randomness okay and uh you must do uh
future injuring in a way that overpasses
this problem
that all right I think I have exited the
slide okay and
uh the third one is uh relatable to the
second one so there are lots of
variables uh uh for example in uh when
we are doing uh when we are doing when
we are having a sample X expensive okay
we may have a lot of variables so one
line of sample may have a lot of
variables and this means that uh between
we have 40 variables and uh let's say
our sample consists of 15 lines
there are high possibilities that there
will be correlated and the rule of thumb
is that for each predicted variable for
each variable that we are predicting on
we need 40 lines of data so when doing
bioengineering you must choose which
which variables are the most important
okay and when you have only the sample
of
120 uh when you have a sample of 120 you
only must choose three predictable three
variables you should predict on because
there is a high chance that this will be
correlated that will be correct
correlation and not causation this is
important
and uh fourth some variables are
estimated or measured what this means
okay uh there are some variables in our
system
that inherently can be measured they are
estimated this this can be inflation
this can be a
unsurvey how do you think
like give an answer from the 0 to 10 how
do you think our president is going to
do this task or something like this okay
this is an estimation that we can't be
sure that this value is 100
uh correct so this value has its own uh
is its own uh
distribution of error and this must be
accounted as well okay
so
uh the time has come for Shameless
plugin uh okay so uh but before the
plugin let's speak about let's speak
about different models Let's uh okay
I'll go to taviolcon
welcome okay
this is my company
okay and the the interesting thing is
that this uh uh the logo you see isn't
generated by graphical interface for
example illustrator or photoshop it is
generated by a function so it's a
mathematical function inside the unit's
circle that has a changing parameter and
it dances and it changes and we have uh
a logo but I want to show one of our
projects that went to these pitfalls so
this uh this is a classification that
classifies this around uh 3
000 different classes and those are
classes so those are our customers and
we want to understand for each customers
for the day we are talking about uh
which uh which uh items they will be
interested in
okay
so in this case
if we use random Forest Ross and Forest
doesn't preform it's it's a model that
gives like in my in my experience one of
the highest metrics in machine learning
okay one of the highest models in
machine metrics in icing model if you
tune it correctly it's very good but it
takes a lot of time to train more
moreover if you have uh 3 000 or so
classes the time goes exponentially
higher okay and it's very expensive to
uh train very it has a very hard model
and it's very hard to implement and it
has a lot of different pitfalls for
example in my experience like random
Forest doesn't provide prediction for
around 20 30 percent of uh classes so it
uh when uh like uh predicting 20 or 30
percent of classes will not have any
prediction so it they won't be shown for
example you have a store
that predicts predicts items for each
and every uh person
20 or 30 percent of your classes or your
return will be not shown at all because
random first maximizes the metrics and
you will have higher metrics
uh like harder function harder model to
implement but it will be have problems
in the real world
and other models may may have a 10
percent less metrics may be 40 time but
maybe 40 times or uh uh
easier to train so the time to train
will be 40 times less they will be
easier to implement on to understand
so and they won't have problems like
this they'll uh give predictions to all
of classes
so this is the thing you must uh
understand okay and uh by the way this
is a working prototype this is uh so the
the this is our work for I did for uh
blueberry and then dusters which is the
representative of those companies in
Armenia and this has a sensitive data so
the the names are randomized and uh a
lot of stuff is hidden here
okay
so
so and uh right let's return
so I've spoken about my
um my uh
my company
and let's speak about our book so uh
this is the second shapeless plug
so uh our book on setting bands which is
the a guide to predicting and regulating
economic processes so uh it's about it's
it's Allah Black Swan
so it discusses the philosophy of
prediction in economy if you are
interested in it's available on Amazon
this book has a my father has written
this book and I had the pleasure to
translate it into English and uh like
and there was a like the amount of
corresponse the correspondence of two
years between the
Publishing House
was on me so uh and it is available on
Amazon and all the major referrals if
you are interested you can look it up
and uh I think that'll be all from my
speech and I'll be awaiting your
questions thank you
[Applause]
are there any questions
by the way uh dinosaurs it's an
interesting story there there is a uscom
quartet as well
uh which about like uh there is a good
topic in statistics that everybody
should know that uh correlation doesn't
imply causation
okay because uh and vice versa
and vice versa
and uh there may be data
that has the similar metrics but uh in
reality isn't the same
you should understand this so are there
any questions
okay
uh thank you for your presentation
you said that there are some chairs that
are estimated uh not correct they have
their own error distribution uh what to
do in that case and uh how to deal with
that features
all right
so
we must okay we can't do a lot this only
shows that
we start with a recipe that has a
built-in error inside and this error
will proceed and small Devils on the way
like each error is a small Devil May
combine into a big devil and this only
shows that if you have estimations
in your project that this doesn't
necessarily mean that the final metric
you have
will have a
a
calculated error the error you must
account that the error will be greater
okay and in a case that we have a lot of
estimations the simpler is the better
all right any more questions I feel like
I haven't uh through uh I feel like like
your Creations is somewhat a metric uh
of my presentation the more the BET as a
one more question
all right then let's end this thank you
[Applause]